in this video we're going to walk
through creating a self-serve
online google cloud billing account if
you are a google cloud user within an
organization
you'll need to have the billing account
creator role in order to perform this
task
if you are not a member of a google
cloud organization but instead are
managing your google cloud resources
using projects
you need no special permissions get
started by heading into the cloud
console
you can start on your organization or
any project home page
then head to the navigation menu in the
left-hand pane
choose billing and then click manage
billing accounts
if you land in the billing overview page
like we did here
you can navigate to manage billing
accounts by expanding the drop-down list
of billing
accounts click create account
give your account a name choose your
organization
if this is applicable in your case and
select the country that corresponds to
your billing address
this will determine your payment options
and currency
note you cannot change the country for a
billing account after it is created
click continue next select an existing
payments profile
or create a new one payments profile
stores your payment
instrument information and defines how
you pay for charges across all of google
to use an existing payments profile you
must have sign up and purchase or
admin with all permissions for the
payments profile
note that permissions for the payments
profile are set by visiting
pay.google.com
and not using the google cloud iam
service
if creating a new payments profile you
must indicate your account type
select business if this is for a
business organization
partnership or educational institution
otherwise
select individual note the account type
cannot be changed after profile creation
then choose a payment method check the
documentation
for more information on which payment
methods are available for your country
finally enter your payment method
details
click submit and enable billing
congratulations
you can now link projects to this
billing account
note that by default the person who
creates the cloud billing account is a
billing account administrator
for the cloud billing account to learn
more about updating billing account and
payments profile settings after creation
follow the link in the description or
head over to the documentation to check
out more details
you